Jennifer: Hi! My name is Jennifer, and I am using jaws for windows as my screen. Reader. I'm using chrome as my browser, and I am using a windows 10 laptop.
Jennifer: And today I am going to be exploring the upskill page because I want to take a course on accessibility. So I'm going to go over here to. So I'm going to go over to my documents.
Jennifer: It's like an accessible. I'm not a million.com copy to let you the playboard, so I can tell you that it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's a
so that's that's what I wanted. I don't.
Jennifer: It's like a, but it's it's like, it's like, it's like, it's like, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it
based on click on
right.
Jennifer: Don't remember, your backward like, but and we'll press the log in button here. So I tabbed over and I'm going to press. Enter here on the login button.
Jennifer: Okay, so here I am on the main page, the main course page, and I am going to look for the accessibility one. So I'm just gonna try to put it on it. Okay, so here I am on the main page, the main course page. And I am going to look for the accessibility one. So I'm just gonna try to put it on a page here, skip to main content. Let's go there. I'll press. Enter to me content.
Jennifer: I don't know if we have to what we can do. But it's okay. And here's the one I want. Introduction to accessibility. S. C. O. R. M. So I'm going to press enter on it.
Jennifer: But there's really more people to be able to deal with. But that's really important. Okay, so here I am in the course. And let's see what we have here. It's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's, it's it's it's it's, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's okay. Well, I'm already 94% complete. Here. maybe the net. Bigland. We got completed.
Jennifer: We don't have to have the complaints. We've got to completely with your experience, but we don't have to. We can't, we don't. We don't. We don't have to. It's it's telling me all the ones that are completed. I went to the bottom of the page. There was a place I can go to the next button or something on the bottom.
Jennifer: So you know, it's it's okay. Look at anybody. Oh, here we go. Continue learning
Jennifer: like, if anybody, I think I press the continue learning button. Let's try it here. Continue your learning. Look at that. You want to press. Enter here.
Jennifer: you know, but it's really it's one thing we'll be able to be linked to anyone who paid for. You don't know if it's but it's it's I think maybe it brought me to where I left off. Let's say here.
Jennifer: what about the engineer calls? We've got the engineering costs. We've got the we've got the. And then the 4 by the extent, adding the 4 by extending on the end of the course. Okay, so it's it's it's actually done. We're going to take a look at it as it goes. We got the number that we're going to. We're going to be able to.
Jennifer: Maybe that's what it's actively. But we can actually do the box with that link. But I'm trying to figure out where I left off for you. But what's what? I'm looking at your phone with the app? There it's it's like all the videos of those kind. You can stop at that time. That will renegade the
Jennifer: sorry press. And I don't. I don't. I don't. I don't. I don't want to be able to. But I don't think it's because it's completed. Let's see if I can find what I need to do yet. Okay, this is, it's completed. Let's see if I can find what I need to do yet. Okay, so this is.
Jennifer: I complain. It's it's it's it's, it's, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's linked with Web completely like all the other company that's playing in. We've got the status actively table with some college editor, of course, table that completed
link on tasks, because it's a couple of like all the tasks you completely like. All the access to companies links me magazines. I've talked about a couple of. We've got the analytically linked to it. Just a couple of like a simple format.
Look at the form, quiz.
Jennifer: It's it's it's completed. It's it's it's it's, it's, it's it's, it's, it's, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's completed. Already. Okay, I mean, just go through this. Then maybe maybe maybe to that. Maybe do that. Take like a legal type of people. But we think, let me maybe do that. And I get to the end of it. It's like, it's
Jennifer: okay. It's as close. I was a little bit confused because it said completed, and I wasn't sure exactly where I needed to go, because I thought I was going to start at the beginning. So maybe this is where I need to be. Okay. All right. All right. So yeah, now, it's since I'm at the end. Okay, I get it. Now.
Jennifer: Okay, where's the next button? But now I figure it out, okay. So it brought me to the completed, since I'm all done with the course. So now it says close button, but it's like what to see here, looking back is same day at least to the main content. Maybe the better we replicate that word. Now we didn't meet it. It's like like with that. It's, it's, it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's, it's it's, it's, it's, it's it's it's it's it's it'
Jennifer: we're then we'll navigate to. We're just going to be able to do. It but it's not that it's okay. So let me view my badges. So I'm going to press. Enter here on the view
Jennifer: Link. Think what you'll label up. You'll think what you'll be able to feel they've 40B min. They want to be able to you same day at least, if they made me better. Here I am on the view badges, paints, we practically navigation, and we'll do it with them with some like, only courses. We don't just delete with that webinar to meet them with that accessibility. Yes. Oh, here we go. I'm supposed to be here. Accessibility champions. I'm going to press. Enter on the accessibility champions, link
Jennifer: plate. What's your label to be able to build up, you'll they'll have more than 6% record maximization. We're going to be able to do it as well as I'm in there, but they're they're going to have it. Anyone who's going to practice them more or less from levels. Remember, I remember looking to reduce building physical products, adding up to the one complemented, Okay, but it's it's only Chinese. It's just a couple of days like probably talking to the more. But I'm going to get the requirement to be done with the adoption, which is Billy store.
Jennifer: So yeah, I was able to find those with no problem and it and it has. The the download badge is a link, and then the is a menu, which is a collapsed menu, and if I
Jennifer: it'll expand it to the options, so I was definitely able to find the badges. I was able to find the links. I was able to find where to go. I was a little bit confused. because I'm used to starting at the beginning of the course, so I was a little bit confused when I got in, and it said it was completed. I wasn't sure exactly what to do, but that just is because I needed a little time to familiarize myself with it.
But other than that, you know, everything was really really accessible and easy to use.
Jennifer: So this completes the task for today, and thank you so much for choosing fable.